[Musik]
das ist die gema zu
schützen eine auslösung durch druckkraft
sternförmigen druckfehler wirkung spreng
so schaut sie aus einer hand habe und
so schaut sie aus und so verlegte
das ist der 2a es ist eine schützende
aufstocken die wirkung ist sprengt ist
ja auch deine splitterwirkung wird
ausgelöst durch einen zug traut der mann
dar und zeigt jetzt wie hoch
das ist die b 106 seine schützen mine
aus lösung wird druck wir kommen sprengt
so schaut sie aus und so schaut seiner
ausreise verlegt ist
was ist die band samt thema mainz wie
der name schon sagt bietet sich bietet
richten sich diese auch von jenen gegen
panzer oder auch andere gepanzerte
fahrzeuge nicht mehr den schützen
ausgelöst wird sie durch druck hier ist
eindruck welcher material besteht aus
eisen und
so sieht sie aus und so sieht's aus wenn
sie verliebt
was ist die themen 260 ist eine
panzermine
ausdruck gehäuse ist aus metall und so
sieht es aus wenn sie länger dem feld
liegt
also wir befinden uns jetzt hast du
diesen platz wo der sucher der als
nächstes in die late als beobachter
fungiert der sitz tor und beobachtete
sucher der in der working erwartet um
sicherzustellen dass daraus nichts
schief geht oder dass da irgendwas
passiert da sitzt und wartet dann geht
weiter
wir gehen jetzt in die existenz der ex
ist natürlich frei vom kampfmittel und
auch klar markiert passieren konnte gar
nix wir gehen dann fuhr bis zum tv vorst
einander vor wirkung ob dort muss jeder
suche den mindestschutz haben oder wer
auch immer diese working area betrieb
wir werden das geld passieren das ist
extra gekennzeichnet
ab dieser ablauf linie ist der
mindestschutz für jeden der in dieser
oder in diesem bereich kommt zu trauen
das heißt entweder von bomben schutz
nahm zugleich die jacke plus einen neben
entsprechenden helm deren richtiges
visier aufweist wann kommen wir in dem
bereich wo unsere sucher die amina suche
in seiner working er seine arbeit
verrichtet das heißt er ist ein all-in
und sucht in diesem gebiet
nach kampfmitteln jeglicher art das
heißt das ist ein kampfmittel belastet
das gelände nicht nur minen im
speziellen fangen alle möglichen
militärischen
kampfmitteln liedern durch den
kampfmittelräumer am ende nach der
schule die seit ich oder geräumt werden
diese suche erstreckt sind natürlich
über wochen dauert und braucht seine
zeit am ende ist da voll gegeben und wir
haben diese was working area erfolgreich
beendeten ziehst du mit kampfmittel frei
und freigegeben für die öffentlichkeit
oder eben für die militärischen zwecken
[Musik]